pink towers and giant dragons sounds  like a scene from a fairy tale but in  this case it's not  [Music]  in the sampron district sits one of  thailand's most unique temples  is a pink shrine dedicated to the  buddhist faith and measures 260 feet or  80 meters high representing the age of  buddha when he died while the temple is  known for the giant encircling dragon  its meaning remains a mystery  bavano budo the founder of the temple  was inspired to create the hollow dragon  building during a seven day fasting  meditation construction took only 5  years  visitors can climb the stairs of the 17  story temple to touch the dragon's beard  or they can climb inside the belly of  the beast  this temple is a must visit for people  looking to discover something truly  one-of-a-kind  [Music]  you